[Applause]
it's time to get candy fied and build a
home for the holidays
i'm jackie sorkin and i'm known as the
candy queen with my team of exceptional
candy artists we're taking on our
biggest project yet we have just six
weeks to create a life-size fully
functional holiday candy house
the whole house the whole it's gonna be
covered in candy like legend that's
right a thousand square feet every
surface
accessory piece of furniture it will all
be candified
this lady is insane it's like i have my
very own team of candy artist elves how
are we gonna get this done we're just
gonna go and go and go and go and go i
don't need sleep i want all the details
to just come to life
i have never blow torched candy before
no oh mike but i did find a new tutorial
online
oh god stop laughing like that you make
me so nervous it's okay boo we got this
hundreds of thousands of pieces of candy
600 000 sugar cubes 96 thousands of
cupcakes i'm feeling stressed out i am
trying not to transfer your stress onto
my stress to create double stress which
is the explosion of stress and making me
die
i often want to say there's no crying in
candy
there is so
much crying and candy mr squeakers is
gonna be good as new okay
we need to get into the holiday spirit
let's go to work
i love you guys you did all of this
i am going to make your dreams come true
total fantasy come to life i love this
[Music]
it's like that perfect holiday moment
you can feel it right